tami stars Melissa McCarthy and it's a
story about a down-on-her-luck woman
she's just not doing well in any aspect
of her life her job isn't working out
her personal life isn't working out her
relationships aren't working out in the
first five minutes of this movie make
that very clear well she's having an
argument with her mom we quickly panned
to a room and we see her grandmother's
played by Susan Sarandon she has a
couple thousand dollars and she doesn't
like where she is so they embark on a
road trip and what we get is a film that
is billed as a road trip comedy but it's
really a drama in disguise now I like
Melissa McCarthy I think she's a very
talented comedian I've seen her in roles
in the past where she did a very good
job and she seems like a really sweet
person in real life but for the past few
years I've been looking in her career
thinking she is just getting typecast in
the same role over and over again and
when I saw the preview for Tammy I was
like she's getting typecast again until
I realized that her husband directed
this film and he and her wrote it she's
reading these scripts she's choosing
them and now she's writing them she's
just playing the same character over and
over again and in Tammy holy crap it
doesn't work at all when your films
opening scene is your main character
hitting a CGI deer with her car and then
trying to resuscitate it by blowing air
into its mouth from a distance your film
is going nowhere fast
the film takes like 10-15 minutes
setting up all these other issues and
then they don't really have anything to
do with the movie they're just
supporting characters that are just kind
of there that's one of my biggest
complaints with this movie it takes
really talented people people like
Alison Janey Kathy Bates Sandra Oh Dan
Aykroyd and just sidelines them into
these roles in which they do nothing
it's like when they were writing their
script they were just like who's really
famous that can play these random side
roles well we'll get some people who are
pretty talented and we'll just kind of
thrown there but they won't get to do
anything my biggest complaint with this
movie is that it's just not frickin
funny at all I laughed
not once during this film not one time
did I laugh during this movie a lot of
shots in this movie feel incredibly lazy
where they're just held for five to ten
seconds longer than they should
the comedic beats do not work because of
this it just seems like a lot of times
the actors are just wandering in and out
of frame telling jokes kind of laughing
trying to be their characters but
they're just sort of honest set laughing
there's a scene in this movie in fact
it's the most widely promoted scene in
the movie where she puts on a paper bag
she's about to rob this burger joint
because she needs money she's in the
parking lot and she's dancing she's
going like this in slow motion and
there's a rap song playing and if you're
not actually paying attention you think
oh that's funny how she's dancing in
slow motion as a rap song but in reality
what in the hell is she doing she's in a
parking lot about to rob a burger joint
and she decides to dance around in the
parking lot and make like gangsta signs
and I'm like what in the world is what
what is she actually doing because in
real life she doesn't have a rap song in
real life there isn't some slow motion
it's just a scene where she goes like
this in slow motion for absolutely no
reason what is actually happening there
why is that in the movie I actually sat
down for about 10 20 minutes trying to
think of something redeeming about Tammy
and I couldn't fight anything when the
words the end came on the screen I was
so excited I got up and I immediately
tried to rush out of the theater and
then two more scenes happen after that
even though it already told me it was
over the film was still trying to stay
around I just and the back of the
theater and watch the two scenes I told
myself Chris watch these two scenes
watching Tammy from start to end is like
a rite of passage just like an
initiation into a very hard to get into
club you watch Tammy all the way from
beginning to end
and you tell yourself you just did
something good for society this was a
terribly unfunny movie that goes from oh
my goodness she fell down let's laugh at
that - let's have a serious crying scene
about death Tammy is a terribly written
film and a very poorly directed one and
I'm not gonna pull any punches on this
one I'm gonna give Tammy an F I feel bad
for Melissa McCarthy and her husband for
writing and directing this it just did
not work out guys you have more talent
than this let's see that on your next
project as you guys know if you've
watched some of my previous reviews Hulu
Plus contacted me and allowed me to
offer you guys - we
of their service for free they want you
guys to go to Hulu Plus comm slash Chris
stuckman and take advantage of that
offer and stick around because I'm
having so much fun watching things on
The Criterion Collection a lot of The
Criterion Collection is on Hulu Plus the
x-files my favorite television show ever
as I grew up is on there as well so much
great entertainment right there at your
fingertips classic movies new TV shows
if you enjoy binge watching like I do
take advantage of this it's two weeks of
Hulu Plus for free guys if you have seen
Tammy first of all I'm sorry what'd you
think of the film and as always thank
you so much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and gets
tokenized